Let's start by talking about what is real-time PBR.
So PBR is a unified light and shading system.
It approximates light in real life behavior.
So you can see these materials kind of reacting in the scene as you would expect that type
of material.
Maybe it either reflects a lot of light or absorbs light and doesn't have as much specularity.
You can dial in these values based on the material, regardless of the type of texture
that you're using.
So we try to create something that's more physically accurate.
So it uses real physical measurements such as lumens and looks and inverse square law,
energy conservation, etc.
And it's just a little bit more intuitive and consistent to understand when you're
creating your projects.
It also produces just a more accurate and natural look, as you can see in these images
here.
When we talk about material concepts with PBR, we generally can divide the materials
we build into metals and non-metals.
So non-metals and metals on the right hand side here, you can see that we can create
the desired approach based on a type of material concept as seen in these images.
So if we're thinking first about base color, which we call an albedo map.
So non-metals, color info always have some kind of range.
There's no pure whites or pure blacks in nature.
So we want to keep in mind a roughness is a key in defining the look of a material
as it's selling in the real world.
So you can see the non-metals here, we have some RGB values and sRGB values, and we might
be approaching if we want a non-metal concept, we might be approaching it more like this.
Whereas a metal concept, again, we'll be using just different information to get our PBR
material to react in a different way.
We have levels of metallic that we can change based on zero to one.
So it's a grayscale value ranging from zero to one.
And the most common usage is either one or zero.
It is more binary in that respect.
So when on, it results in 100% specular reflection, as you can see on the right hand side of the
image here, zero would be on the left hand side, and you can see all the values in between.
Again, it's most common to use either zero or one kind of binary approach.
However, obviously, the results will depend on what effects you're actually going after.
We also have roughness masks, which is again a grayscale value ranging between zero and
one, but roughness materials will scatter the reflected light in more directions than
a smooth material might.
So if you want a more mirrored surface, that is on the zero end this time, a bit more reflective.
And then a more matted surface is going to be the one value here.
So again, you can dial it in from zero to one based on how rough you want that material
to feel.
And then we've got a few credits here.
The room was created by Fabrice Bruehle and we've got some additional resources here on
physically based index.
If you want to dig into those.